ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES BELL.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD.
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALLY.
DODD THERE ARE SO.
GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HUESO -- TADO
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER BY KATHY [inaudible]
WIENER WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LET IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG
BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
SELECT IS CONTINUE -- TO TAKE
OUR DEEP RELAXING BREATHS.
THE FOLLOWING POEM BY GREGORY OR
ILLUSTRATES THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK.
LET'S REMAKE THE WORLD'S WITH
WORDS [inaudible]
NOT FRIVOLOUSLY.
NOR TO HIDE FROM WHAT WE FEAR.
BUDGET WITH A PURPOSE.
LET AS WORDS WORDS SAID.
REMOVE THE DUST OF CUSTOM.
SO THINGS SHINE AGAIN.
EACH OBJECT TO RAGE IN ITS ROBE
OF ORIGINAL LIGHTS.
AND SPEND WILL SEE THE WORLD AS
IF FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AS ONCE WE GAZED AT THE
BELOVED'S WHO WAS GAZING AT US.
CREATE OF GODS WE THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK OF THE SENATE AND STAFF.
WHO LABOR DAILY TO REMAKE THE
WORLD BY THE INFLUENCE OF THEIR
WORDS?
MAY THEY CONTINUE TO DEMONSTRATE
TO US OUR POTENTIAL AS A STATE.
TO NEGOTIATE THE CHALLENGES OF
THE FUTURE.
THROUGH THE CREATIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE INSIDE AND EFFORTS
OF EACH DAY A MAN.
WATER OUR FLAG [inaudible]
THE LOOP. TWO OF HIS FORMER. ONE
ONE INDIVISIBLE WITH
[inaudible] FOR ALL.
I DON'T EITHER [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SHORT WELL SURE WE
ORINDA PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
FOR WHAT PURPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION BRIEFLY.
WE HAVE HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER YET AGAIN.
SENATE IS SENATOR FEUD WAIT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY JUST COMING IN
OKAY SURE THEY'RE GOING TO WANT
TO THEIR WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY.
I COULD ONLY RATHER CONSIDER HIM.
A PHOTO OF HER OKAY TENSION TO
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS QUITE.
QUITE IMPORT EXTRAORDINARY GROUP
OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS I
WAS SUGGESTING WE HAVE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONS IN THE HOUSE.
NATIONAL CHAMPIONS NOT FOR THE
FIRST TIME BUT FOR THE SEVENTH
TIME IN THE LAST NINE YEARS
WINNING THE NATIONAL ACADEMIC
DECATHLON AND THAT'S FROM
GRANADA HILLS CHARTER HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE CASF LINE TEAM UP HERE IN
THE GALLERY AND I WANT TO TELL
YOU SOMETHING.
THESE ARE AMAZING AMAZING
STUDENTS.
THEY LEARN AND SEVEN SUBJECT
AREAS OF SCIENCE AND LITERATURE
ART MUSIC SOCIAL SCIENCE
ECONOMICS AND MATHEMATICS.
AND THE MOST UNIQUE PART AS
THOSE WHO RECALL BECAUSE I HAVE
NOW FOR THE FOURTH TIME MADE
THIS INTRODUCTION ON HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR OF THIS TEAM.
THAT IS NOT JUST A STUDENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE BUT
ACADEMIC DECATHLON TEAMS ARE
REQUIRED TO CONSIST OF STUDENTS
FROM ALL GRADE POINT AVERAGES.
AT IF YOU LOOK AT THEM THEIR
FAMILIES ARE COME FROM EVERY
PART OF THE PLANET.
FROM THE EAST TO THE WEST FROM
THE SOUTH TO THE NORTH THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY TALENTED KIDS I
WANT YOU TO JOIN ME AGAIN IN
CONGRATULATING GRANADA HILLS
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL TEAM.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN NASH SAID
ALTS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO EACH OF YOU
AND TO YOUR PARENTS WHO I'M SURE.
HAD TO ENSURE THE HOURS UP WITH
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU'VE DONE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
KEEP US ON THE MAP AND BEST OF
LUCK IN YOUR FUTURES.
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN
THE MANY LOANS MANAGER WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE SENATOR GROW FOR WHAT
PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THEY'LL BE A REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
IN ROOM THREE OH FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN
ROOM
WE WILL GO.
BACK INTO SESSION.
IF WE COULD HAVE ALL MEMBERS
PLEASE BACK ON THE SENATE FLOOR
SO WE CAN.
OF RE COMMENCE OUR SENATE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY ALL SENATE
MEMBERS PLEASE TO THE SENATE
FLOOR
COLLEAGUES COULD WE HAVE
ALL MEMBERS.
BACK ON THE SENATE FLOOR SO WE
CAN CONTINUE OUR BUSINESS OF THE
DAY
COLLEAGUES ARE WE ARE BACK
IN SESSION.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO SUBDIVISION
A WILL BE WAY FOR THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE TO MEET
ON JUNE NINETEENTH WITHOUT FOUR
DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE.
SENATOR MITCHELL UNDER IN
MOTIONS RESOLUTION AND NOTICES --
YES MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES
FOR BILLS HEARD REPORTED BY THE
BUDGET IN THIS REVIEW COMMITTEE
ON WEDNESDAY JUNE NINETEENTH.
SO THAT THEY'RE ON THIRD READING
AND PROBABLY BEFORE THE HOUSE ON
THURSDAY JUNE [inaudible]
TWENTY THE I ASKED ABOUT THANK
YOU IS THERE OBJECTION SENATOR
NIELSEN OF CHECKS [inaudible]
NO OBJECTION.
THERE IS OBJECTION ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT SENATOR.
WITH THAT SENATOR MITCHELL IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
NIELSEN IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THE RAZZLE.
HI.
GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ.
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL BY MORNING BY MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
IRA CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILK.
NO.
PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME US SENATOR BATES.
I TO KNOW RIGHT MR SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BATES I
DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
STONE.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
N. CENTER MITCHELL FOR PURPOSE.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEMBERS I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES FOR
A. B. NINETY ONE IN ORDER THIS
BILL TO THIRD READING.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
THERE IS OBJECTION.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATOR
MITCHELL'S ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE SENATOR NIELSEN ASKING FOR
NO VOTE MATTER A MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG.
NO.
DALY.
NO DODD.
HI.
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK NO MORALE
[inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BARBARA COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
NOPE.
I TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
COLLEAGUES AGAIN UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES -- WOULD
ANYONE LIKE TO TAKE ANY ITEM OFF
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT REQUEST
THE AUTHOR.
AT ACID YOU REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE AB TWELVE ALL
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL FROM THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT COUNTER.
THAT WILL BE THE ORDER.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WE WILL GO CONTINUE BACK
WITH.
I'M SORRY SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOUNG REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I
LIKE TO REMOVE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN AB. ONE EIGHT ONE FOUR
THAT WILL BE SO NOTED.
THANK YOU.
ITEM [inaudible] EIGHTEEN
FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
SENATOR ON BURKE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE ARE THERE ANY
OTHER REQUESTS.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
AND FIRST LET'S GO BACK MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
MADAM PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTION
FORMER AUTOBODY THAT THE SIMPLY
AMENDED AND ON THIS DAY PASSED
AS AMENDED SENATE BILL.
838-485-8790 TWO NINETY THREE
NINETY FOUR NINETY FIVE NINETY
SIX SENATE BILL ONE OF THREE ONE
OH FIVE SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN SENATE BILL.
EIGHTY TWO AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR ALL BY TWO KERN SAID
AMENDMENTS.
THE DATSUN WILSON CHIEF CLERK OF
THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILLS ORDER
TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVING ON NOW TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
UNDER THE SECOND READING FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY ONE
WITH THE MOMENTS ELEVEN HUNDRED
WITH A MOMENT'S SIXTY FIVE THE
MEMBERS TO TWENTY EIGHT WITH
MEMBERS TEN FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS AS A MAJORA'S
SOLUTION. ELEVEN WITH WOMEN'S
ASSEMBLY BILL SOME FOURTEEN IN
SOME LEGAL.
NINETY FOUR AND NOW WE WILL GO
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WERE
SENATOR WILK IS ANXIOUS TO
PRESENT FILE ITEMS NINE THROUGH.
ELEVEN WE'LL START WITH FILE
ITEM NINE CENTER WILL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR MARK
GALLI AS SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. FOR THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS DOCTOR GALLEY
SERVED IN VARIOUS COUNTY HEALTH
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO.
HIS PRIOR CLINICAL WORK INCLUDE
SEEING PATIENTS AT THE LA COUNTY
JUVENILE DETENTION SYSTEM.
AND THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR OUTPATIENT MEDICAL HUB
THE SERVICE FOSTER YOUTH.
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
HE WAS APPROVED BY RULES
COMMITTEE ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE ON
THE FIFTH OF JUNE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILL CAUSE HER
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO SENATORS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SECRETARY OR
DOCTOR GOLLY -- WELL I DO NOT
REALLY KNOW PERSONALLY PRIOR TO
HIM BECOMING SECRETARY HAD
PLEASURE OF ME WITH HIM AND
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH HIM --
SINCE IS -- INITIAL APPOINTMENT
AND WHAT RECOGNIZE THAT HE ALSO
SHARED MAY THE SAME PROFESSORS I
DID IN HIS TRAINING HE WOULD
BOTH US -- WENT TO MAY THE SAME
SCHOOLS AND I THINK HE'S GOING
TO DO AN EXCELLENT JOB FOR THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA AND TONIGHT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENN ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NON CENTER
WELL DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL.
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DAILY.
I DODD.
HI THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TADO.
I JACKSON BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY MORE LUCK.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY.
BY WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL HER WE WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL.
MOVING ALONG TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
TEN SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN IS
A CONFIRMATION OF ALE BRODSKY
CHEMICAL ACS AND THERE ARE SURE
TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING COUNCIL.
MISS BRODSKY AN ATTORNEY FROM
OUR LINDA HAS SERVED ON THE
COUNCIL SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN MR IGLESIAS A PROFESSOR
OF LAW AT THE UNIVERSITY SAN
FRANCISCO.
HAS SERVED ON THE COUNCIL SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN MISH
MASH SIR -- SURE -- LITIGATE
COUNSEL AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA FROM BERKELEY HAS
SERVED ON THE COUNCIL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN EVERY
EXPECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BELL.
BY PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY.
I I'D DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
HI GONZALEZ.
BY HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON HI BY JONES
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
SENATOR WILK MOVES TO CALL
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND IF YOU DRAW YOUR ATTENTION.
TO SENATOR MORALE.
THANK YOU YOUR THE FORESHORES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM JUST -- VERY HAPPY
AND PLEASED TO BOB -- WELCOME TO
PEOPLE HAVE WE COME MY FRIENDS --
IT AYE AYE THESE TWO MEN CAME TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF A BILL THAT
I HAVE. TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
DISABLED VETERANS WOULD YOU
PLEASE WELCOME IN THE BACK -- OF
THE FLOOR HERE MISTER ARE YOU J.
R. WILL SEND.
AND ALSO ALEX HOW REIJI ARM AN
ELEVEN YEAR.
VETERAN AND BOTH THESE MEN
SERVED OUR COUNTRY AND THEY PAID
DEARLY AND SO WOULD YOU JUST
WELCOME THEM.
PLEASE THANK YOU.
A WARM WELCOME. TO OUR VETERANS.
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE
SIR ON THIS ISSUE BY MAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
BETTER PRESENT LAYS DOWN I JUST
WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THE
HONORING OF THESE THESE WARRIORS.
AND THE PRICE THEY PAID.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MISTER WILSON
SO MUCH BUT I KNOW MR HER
REGULAR VERY WELL.
AND WHAT A HERO HE HAS BEEN.
HAS CONTINUED TO THE SENSHI.
GONE THROUGH IS LONG HEALING AND
CAME BACK.
RESOLVE TO NOT BE DEFEATIST IN
SORROW FOR HIMSELF.
BUT TO BE A BETTER HUMAN BEING.
AND THE CARE THAT BEYOND HIS OWN
AROUND. TOO MANY OTHERS.
THAT IS VERY TYPICAL OF THOSE
WHO HAVE PAID A PRICE.
WHO HAVE SURVIVED [inaudible]
AND THEN.
GET BACK FOR MORE.
WE MUST REALLY APPRECIATE THEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN I
BELIEVE EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
CONCURS WITH YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU.
GENTLEMAN
.
AT THIS.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OF SENATOR WELL
FOR THE LAST OF THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS TODAY WHICH IS FILE
ITEM. ELEVEN SENATOR WILL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
IS A CONFIRMATION OF JERRY
FLEMING AND DR SANDRA HERNANDEZ.
REAPPOINTMENT TO THE COVER
CALIFORNIA GOVERNING BOARD.
AND LAURIE LUCIANO FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE.
FIVE WITH THE UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK SENATOR
PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
CENTERS -- CERTAINLY IN FAVOR OF
THE TO RE APPOINTEES THE MEMBERS
A COVER CALIFORNIA I DO WISH TO
EXPRESS SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE
MEDICAL BOARD APPOINTEE -- IS TO
BE I KNOW WHO I AND UNDERSTAND
IS A NEW APPOINTEE SHE'S A LAY
PERSON ATTORNEY -- I THINK THAT
SHE SOMEONE BRINGS A LOT OF
TALENT TO THE BOARD -- BUT AFTER
THAT IN HER IN THE LAST AND
RECENT BOARD MEETING -- SHE DID
MAKE SOME REMARKS.
WHERE ARE WERE CONCERNING TO ME
AS A PHYSICIAN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT MEMBERS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND THEIR ROLE IN
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND --
NEED TO UNDERSTAND -- THE ISSUES
AROUND SCIENCE.
AND ALSO -- STANDARD OF CARE.
AND SOME OF THE REMARKS MADE
WERE NOT CONSISTENT WITH THOSE --
NOW SHE IS A NEW BOARD MEMBER
AND SHE IS SOMEONE FROM MY OWN
COMMUNITY THE API COMMUNITY SO
WHY.
NOT GONNA ASK PEOPLE WILL NOT
VOTE FOR HER I UNDERSTAND SHE
WILL HAVE TWO YEARS TO PROVE
HERSELF SHE'S BY LEARNING AS
HE'S -- COMING ON TO THE BOARD
SO ASSET PEOPLE VOTE FOR HER BUT
I ALSO HOPE.
THAT -- IS SHE LEARNS TO BE A
MEMBER OF THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT --
THAT -- SHE WILL ALSO -- LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
STANDARD OF CARE AND SCIENCE IN.
TERMS OF JUDGMENT AND POLICY SO --
WITH THAT -- I DO ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE -- BUT I ALSO I WANT TO
SHARE THIS NOTE OF CAUTION THAT
I HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY FURTHER
[inaudible]
STRONG NEUTRALITY.
SENATOR WILK YOU MAY CLOSE I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR -- FOR
FROM SACRAMENTO FIRST FOR
SHARING HIS THOUGHTS WITH THE
BODY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
BY PORCHES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LARK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
TYLER CASKEY BY WIENER.
BY WILK HI.
SENATOR WILL MOVES A CALL.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
TO SENATE THIRD READING FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTEEN SENATE THIRD READING.
SENATOR BRADFORD MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO JUNETEENTH SENATOR
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT AS C. R..
FIFTY EIGHT I SEE ARE FIFTY
EIGHT COMMEMORATES JUNE
EIGHTEENTH AS A DAY OF HONOR AND
REFLECTS ON THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
AND HISTORY OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT KNOWLEDGE IS THE FAILURE
OF JUSTICE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS.
AND REALLY THE LACK OF TRUTH
WHEN IT COMES TO AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THIS MEASURE RECOGNIZES JUNE
NINETEENTH. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS JUNETEENTH
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
ALSO COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
EMANCIPATION DAY OR FREEDOM DAY
WHEN THE LAST SLAVES IN AMERICA.
WERE FREE.
SPECIALLY IN THE STATE OF TEXAS
AND LOUISIANA AND BEING FROM
TEXAS THIS HOLIDAY AND MY FAMILY
AND MY GRANDPARENTS IN THEIR
THEM BEFORE THEM WITH CELEBRATED
MORE SO.
THAN INDEPENDENCE DAY BECAUSE
THIS WAS TRULY THEIR
INDEPENDENCE AND MANY ARE FOR
AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT LINCOLN ISSUED THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION IN.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO DEMANDING
THAT THE CONFEDERATE STATES
RETURNED TO THE UNION OR THEIR
SLAVES WOULD BE PERMANENTLY FREE.
THAT ORDER WAS IGNORED.
IT TOOK TWO AND A HALF YEARS FOR
THE MESSAGE OF FREEDOM TO REACH
TAXES AND GRANITE THERE WAS NO --
CELL PHONES INSTAGRAM AND ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T TAKE IN TWO
HUNDRED MI TWO AND A HALF YEARS
IT WAS CLEARLY DELIBERATELY
DELAYED IN GETTING THAT MESSAGE
TO THE SOUTHERN STATES
ESPECIALLY AGAIN.
LOUISIANA AND TEXAS FREEDOM
DELAYED WAS FREEDOM DENIED.
GENERAL GORDON GRANGER LET
THOUSANDS OF FEDERAL TROOPS TO
GALVESTON TEXAS TO ANNOUNCES
CIVIL WAR HAD ENDED.
AND SLAVES WERE NOW FREE
THOUSAND SLAVES IN TEXAS WERE
NOT AWARE OF THEIR FREEDOM.
HAVE BEEN SECURED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
FREEDOM DID NOT ONLY COULD NOT
COME EASILY.
EVEN AFTER THE NOTICE MANY WERE
STILL FORCED TO WORK FAR BEYOND
THEIR EMANCIPATION INTO THE
HARVEST SEASON.
MANY SLAVE OWNERS CONTINUE TO
TREAT THE FREEDMAN.
AS CHATTEL.
THE SLAVE THE GAPS THE NEW THEIR
FREEDOM WAS ONLY THE FIRST STEP.
NOT ONLY FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
THE DATE IS NOT JUST ABOUT A
CELEBRATION A RECOGNITION IT'S
ABOUT REFLECTING ON SOME THE
HORRIFIC EVENTS THAT HAPPEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND DECADES AFTER THE END OF
CIVIL WAR THIS NATION WITNESS SO
WAIT A WAVE OF LYNCHING.
IMPRISONMENT AND JIM CROW LAWS
WERE STILL SUFFERING FROM SOME
OF THE FAILURES OF JUSTICE THAT
WERE PORTRAYED UPON AFTER
AMERICANS EVEN IN THIS DAY OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN ONE PRIME
EXAMPLE IS THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
IT'S THE BILL THAT'S BEEN
DEBATED HEAVILY IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND IF WE
LEGISLATE FROM JUST A DAY WE SAY
WHAT'S WRONG WITH OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT BUT IF WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HISTORICAL CONTENT.
DO YOU THINK DALY FORCE WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO AND DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
FREE BLACK MAN IN THIS STATE AND
IN THIS NATION.
WE STILL SEE THE DISPLAY
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
INADEQUATE SCHOOL SYSTEMS THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE MASS
INCARCERATION DISCRIMINATION
HOUSING POLICIES THE LACK OF
ECONOMIC INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ALL THE REMNANTS OF SLAVERY.
THE X. LEYVA GALLAS AND HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO FIGHT FOR THEIR
FREEDOM.
BUT THEIR FEARLESS AND
RELENTLESS PURSUIT SHOULD SERVE
AS AN INSPIRATION TO US THE
CIVIC LEADERS.
AND OUR SHARED GOAL OF APPROVED
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF
BONDAGE AND SERVER TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS A
RICH SOCIETY THROUGH OUR
STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
PROMOTING UNITY.
THE QUALITY AND OUR INGENUITY.
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
NOT LET THIS STATE JUST BE A DAY
OF CELEBRATION AS STATED.
AND REMIND US THAT FREEDOM IS
NOT FREE FREEDOM CAME WITH A
HEAVY PRICE TAG AND THE LOSS OF
LIFE.
AS POLICY MAKERS WE MUST ENSURE
THAT JUSTICE AND FREEDOM AND
IT'S NATION IS NEVER LAW THAT
THE LATE.
BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT.
WE TELL OUR REAL HISTORY IT'S
IMPORTANT WE TELL A REAL REAL
HISTORY AND NOT WHITE WASH AND
SANITIZE NOT TO WHITEWASH AND
SANITIZED VERSION ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
DEBATER DISCUSSIONS SENATOR
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF A C.
R. FIFTY EIGHT COMMEMORATING
JUNE.
JUNETEENTH NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO BRING AWARENESS TO THE
CONTRIBUTIONS WOMEN MADE IN THE
FIGHT FOR EMANCIPATION.
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS WE HAVE
SEEN THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
DELAY OF THE NEW TWENTY DOLLAR
BILL FEATURING FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER A WOMAN.
AND A WOMAN OF COLOR WE HAVE ALL
HEARD HARRIET TUBMAN'S ACTS OF
COURAGE BRAVERY.
AND HEROISM I WOULD SAY SHIRO
ISM FROM LEADING SLAVES TO
FREEDOM THROUGH THE UNDERGROUND
RAIL ROAD TO BECOMING A SPY FOR
THE UNION DURING THE CIVIL WAR.
HOWEVER SHE WAS NOT ALONE
FRANCIS EW HARPER ELIZABETH
FREEMAN SERRA PARKER.
SIR JUNIOR TRUTH AND MANY MORE
TODAY LET US HONOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF BLACK WOMEN.
NOT ONLY WERE THESE WOMEN
FIGHTING FOR WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE
THEY WERE ALSO LEADERS IN THE
FIGHT FOR EMANCIPATION.
EACH ONE OF THEM CARVE OUT THEIR
OWN PLACE IN AMERICAN HISTORY BY
GIVING VOICE TO THE EXPERIENCES
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
SETTING LEGAL PRECEDENT FOR THE
OLD UP ABOLITION.
ABOLITION SORRY ABOUT THAT.
OF SLAVERY FILING LAWSUITS
AGAINST THEIR SLAVE OWNERS AND
REFUSING TO GIVE UP A SEAT IN A
PHILADELPHIA TROLLEY BUT IT'S
NOT FORGET THAT AMERICA'S
HISTORY WAS CREATED BY MEN AND
WOMEN.
OF ALL BACKGROUNDS AND
EXPERIENCES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I STAND RISES -- VICE
CHAIR OF THE API LET'S SAY
CAUCUS TO STAY IN A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION WHAT
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
GUARDINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I THINK IT THE THE CELEBRATION
IS AN IMPORTANT ONE THAT MARKS A
IMPORTANT STAFF BUT A
RECOGNITION THAT ALSO THAT --
WHILE PEOPLE CELEBRATED THEIR
NEW FOUND FREEDOM AT THAT TIME
THE JOURNEY SO LONG MANY
SACRIFICE OR STILL TO BE MADE.
AND BUT WE NEED TO CELEBRATE
EACH OF THOSE.
VICTORIES AND THEN RECOGNIZE
THAT WE STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO AND I WANT AGAIN THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FOR BRING THIS --
RESOLUTION FORD IN RECOGNITION
OF THIS ERY IMPORTANT PART OF
AMERICAN HISTORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PAN ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE -- FROM
SACRAMENTO AND FROM DILLON
EMPIRE AND THIS MORNING I WAS
APPROACHED BY OUR THIS AFTERNOON
I WAS APPROACHED BY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN AUS WHAT IS THE
SIGNIFICANCE.
OF THE RED SODA POP THAT'S
EITHER ON YOUR TEST OR HE'S
STILL INSIDE YOUR DEBTS.
IN THE RED IS A SIGNIFICANT.
COLOR A MEETING FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND WE'RE FOR OFTEN
STEREOTYPED.
OF FOR OUR AFFINITY TO
WATERMELON BUT IT'S NOT THE
FRUIT ITSELF IT'S WHAT IT
SYMBOLIZED THE RED IN THE SODA
POP AS WELL AS A RED IN THE
WATERMELON.
IN THE RED AND RED VELVET CAKE
THAT W'VE ALL ENJOYED AT SOME
POINT IN OUR LIFE IT'S A SYMBOL
SYMBOLIZES THE BLOOD THAT AFTER
AN AMERICAN SHE YET.
IN THIS COUNTRY AS SLAVES IN THE
CIVIL WAR AND FOR FREEDOM AND
SINCE BEING FREE IT'S BEEN A
SYMBOLIC.
GESTURE AND FOOD AND DRINK.
ALL FOR LAST HUNDRED YEARS
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AND
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT UP WHY
WOULD WE HAVE READ SODA POP.
WHY WE?
HAVE WATER MELON AT MOST OF OUR
EVENTS IT'S NOT BECAUSE AFTER
AMERICANS HAVE ANY GREATER
AFFINITY FOR THE THE FRUIT BUT
IT SOME SYMBOLISM OF AGAIN THE
BLOOD THE SACRIFICE.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
INGENUITY THAT -- WE HAVE SHARED
WITH THIS COUNTRY THE COUNTRY SO
I WANT TO HELP EDUCATE NOT ONLY
MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THROUGHOUT THE
CITY CALIFORNIAN IMPORTS.
BUT I APPRECIATE CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL FOR STATE
IN THE UNION -- HAWAI MONTANA
AND THE DAKOTAS TO STILL HAVE
FAILED TO RECOGNIZE --
JUNETEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES.
I BILL BY PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
HI COUNTY AT ALL.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
I DOT.
I THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
TIME ACQUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER
OUR COUNTY I WINNER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY OF I BELIEVE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE OF CALL WILL
MOVE A CALL CENTER BRADFORD
MOVES TO CALL.
BEFORE WE GO BACK WE'RE GONNA GO
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND IT IS MY DISTINCT HONOR --
AND WOULD ASK OUR COLLEAGUES.
TO OF PLEASE WELCOME TO OUR
FLOOR THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LANEY COULD UNLOCK IS WITH HER
NEPHEW ANGELO.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE RED CARPET
[inaudible]
END UP.
THANK YOU FR JOINING US SEND US
SOME DAY YOU MAY YEAH.
PUT ON A COAT AND TIE AND JOIN
US.
WELCOME AGAIN HONOR TO HAVE OUR
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE HERE
WITH US TODAY.
MY COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVE NOW.
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
[inaudible]
RED.
EXCUSE ME WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
THE BUDGET A SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER.
ONE SENATOR MITCHELL ARE YOU.
READY TO PROCEED THERE WE ARE
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ THIS TO THE SENATE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER.
ONE FILE ITEM ONE OH THREE YEAH.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RING.
SENATE BILL ONE OF FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE IMPRESSION FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT GOING TO
CORRECTIONS AND MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATE
TO THE BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THE
NEXT SEVERAL ITEMS WILL BE
TAKING UP -- ALL OUR TRAILER
BILLS THAT WILL HELP --
OPERATIONALIZE THE BUDGET BILL
IN CHIEF THAT WE VOTED ON LAST
WEEK I'LL BEGIN WITH SENATE BILL
ONE ALL [inaudible] FIVE IF THE
TRAILER BILL THAT MAKES CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IN THAT CORRECTIONS
FINANCING PROVISIONS OF THE
BUDGET ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM.
THE BILL MOST SIGNIFICANTLY DOES
TWO THINGS INCREASES THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT OF COSTS AUTHORIZE FROM
ONE POINT OH NINE BILLION TO ONE
POINT ONE BILLION. FOR ALL
PROJECTS UNDER CDC ARGUE
RESTRICTION THIS INCLUDES
PROJECT THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCT
NEWER RENOVATE EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND AN ANCILLARY AND
ANY ANCILLARY IMPROVEMENTS
PROVIDE MEDICAL DENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT OR
HOUSING.
SECONDLY IT MAKES AN ADDITIONAL
FORTY NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR ANY
PROJECT ESTABLISHED BY THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD.
AND THE H. C. F. I. P. PORTFOLIO
SUBJECT TO EXISTING REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THAT EACH ALLOCATION
BE APPROVED BY THE BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SUPPORT
SPECIFIED INFORMATION TO THE
JAIL B. C. AND THE FISCAL
COMMITTEES OF EACH HOUSE AT
LEAST TWENTY DAYS.
BEFORE THE BOARD'S APPROVAL I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
LOOSER ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE OH THREE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THE RAZA.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI.
ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN BY STONE
[inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
HI.
SENATOR MITCHELL MOVES TO CALL.
MOVIE GONE.
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FOUR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUT IN FISCAL
REVIEW AN ECHO IN EDUCATION
FINANCE AND MAKE IN PREPARATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT MERELY
BILL RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS OUR EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL IT MAKES CHANGES TO
THE PROCESS FOR CERTIFYING THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
SPECIFICALLY ELIMINATING THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT COST
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE CREATED IN
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND
PROHIBITING THE STATE FOR MAKING
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING LEVEL ONCE
AT THIS SCHOOL YEAR IS OVER.
THE BILL CAPS THE COLA FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
CONTINUOUS.
IF.
THE CALL EXCEED THE GROWTH OF
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
FINALLY THIS BILL APPROPRIATES
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP NINETY
EIGHT SUBLET BUNS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOR VARIOUS CASE TO
FOURTEEN PROGRAMS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AM I
TO ASK FOR A AYE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM AND I THINK THE BUDGET
CHAIR FOR MAKING SURE THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE DISTRICTS NINETY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULAS.
IN THIRTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
TO SUPPORT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHICH IS DESPERATELY NEEDED IN A
LOT OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM SO I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
I COLLEAGUES WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH --
THE ROLE TWICE AND THEN CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THE SIDE.
MISTER SECRETARY EXCUSE ME
SENATOR WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA BY ATKINS AYE BATES.
BY BILL [inaudible]
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DAILY [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ.
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
LEYVA.
TIME REQUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
AYE MOORLACH.
MORRELL.
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BOB CASSIE.
I WINNER.
HI WILK PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS JONES.
BY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN.
BY PRICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE FOR CHOOSE ME ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORDANT.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ITEM.
WHICH IS FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FIVE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE BILL SEVENTY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT GOING.
TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION IN
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS IS MORE GOOD NEWS IN THE
FIELD OF EDUCATION THIS IS THE
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL EXPANDS ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID HELPING TO MAKE
HIGHER EDUCATION MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IT CREATES THE CAL GRANT ACCESS
TO WORK FOR STUDENTS PARENTS
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE LIVING
EXPENSES OF STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN.
AND INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS
WHICH ARE TARGETED TOWARDS OUR
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS FROM
250-007-5240 ONE THOUSAND AWARDS.
EXPAND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM TO AUTHORIZE
COLLEGES TO WAY FOR YOU FOR
FIRST TIME FULL TIME STUDENTS
FOR TWO ACADEMIC YEARS.
AND IT ESTABLISHES THE CAL GRANT
BE SERVICE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
LASTLY THIS BILL MAKES
MODIFICATIONS TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
COLLEAGUES I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DOT.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ.
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NOPE LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
NO.
I'M BURKE.
I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO.
ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE OH SIX MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY TWO BY THE
COMING INVASION FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACTING STATE GOVERNMENT IN
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT MERELY BILL
RELATED BUT SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AND STATE
ADMINISTRATION.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT ESTABLISHES THE
OFFICE OF DIGITAL INNOVATION IT
RESTRUCTURE THE FEES SET BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL FOR ITS LICENSEES.
IT MAKES VERY FOR CHANGES
RELATED TO ELECTIONS AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY ISSUES DEPOSIT THE
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
IN THE SAFETY NET RESERVE FUND
BRINGING THE FUN TO A TOTAL OF
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IT REQUIRES THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP A RISK
BASED APPROACH FOR AUDITING
UTILITY BALANCING ACCOUNTS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
SIX SENATOR GROWTH.
SORRY SORRY MADAM PRESIDENT FOUR
DOORS I AM I APPRECIATE ALL THE
GOOD THINGS THAT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION DOES THIS TRAILER
BILL DOES -- WITH REGARDING TO
WHAT THE SENATE BUDGET CHAIR
JUST ADDRESSED HOWEVER THERE IS
SOMETHING ON THERE THAT WE
FOUGHT FOR AS REPUBLICANS FOR A
LONG TIME ALMOST NINE YEARS.
THAT'S A DEVELOPMENTAL COMMUNITY
WE SIGNED ON TO A LETTER EVERY
REPUBLICAN IN THIS HOUSE AND THE
ASSEMBLY SAYING THAT WE WANTED
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE DD COMMUNITY WHICH IS
OUR MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY.
THESE PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN GET OUT
OF BED WITH SOME WITHOUT SOMEONE
HELPING THEM.
AND WHEN IT CAME BACK AND I
APPLAUD THE BUDGET YOU'RE FOR
FIGHTING FOR THE DOLLARS THAT WE
DID GET I REALLY DO.
HE AME BACK WITH TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WE'VE
COMMISSIONED A RATE STUDY WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
RATES STEADY SAID THAT WHEN IT
FINALLY CAME OUT THAT WE WERE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
LESS THEY STILL NEED A BILLION
DOLLARS JUST OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
THESE PROGRAMS WORK IN ALL OF
OUR DISTRICTS FOR MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
IN THIS BUDGET FUNDS THEM FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THEY CANNOT MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE THE PROGRAMS
THAT THEY OFFER OUR MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
THAT DAY CARES AND OTHER
FACILITIES THAT WORK WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT YOU'RE ABOUT READY TO VOTE
ON ISOLATES OUT THE CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER FOR SALE
BECAUSE WE CLOSED OUT THAT
INSTITUTION.
NOW WHEN WE HAD DD INDIVIDUALS
INSIDE THAT INSTITUTION THE
INSTITUTION FULLY WAS FUNDED
COMPLETELY FUNDED MAINTENANCE.
M. ALL THE INFORMATION ALL ALL
THE INFORMATION FOR THAT DD
COMMITTEE WAS COMPLETELY FUNDED
AND THOSE PEOPLE WERE TAKING
CARE OF AND THEN AFTER THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS PASSED.
THAT MONEY WILL NOT BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE COMMUNITY FOR
DD'S COMMUNITY SO I ASKED -- I
ASKED FOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BAY A NO VOTE BASED
ON THAT INFORMATION.
AND I APOLOGIZE IF I HAVE THE
WRONG BILL BECAUSE IT APPEARS
THAT IDEA [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU WERE CENTER GROVE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- MY RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- I A FIRST OF ALL
I WANT -- TO RECOGNIZE AND THAT --
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HERE FOR
THE IDT COMMUNITY CERTAINLY AND
OUR ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE
BUDGET THAT WE PASS THAT.
YEAR AND SENATE -- WE CERTAINLY
STRIVE TO TRY TO GET MORE
FUNDING I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
CERTAINLY -- IN OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES WE ARE PLAN TO FOLLOW
UP ON THE RATE STUDY AND I THINK --
THEY ARE MINORITY LEADER -- AND
YOU KNOW -- DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
IN DESCRIBING WHAT THE RATES --
WHAT THE RACE THAT HE CALLED FOR
AND CERTAINLY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT?
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THOUGH THAT --
THAT THE SIMILAR DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER IS NOT BEING SOLD -- THAT
THAT'S THAT'S NOT WHAT'S IN THIS
BUDGET THAT IT IS HELD WE HEARD
THIS AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE --
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IN FACT IT'S A FUNDING
IS ALLOCATED TO CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN THOSE FACILITIES WHICH
IS VERY IMPORTANT NOW WE HAVE TO
BE SURE WE CONTINUE MEETING THE
FACILITIES.
AND THERE IS SOME -- PAYMENT TO
CINEMA COUNTY. TO IN TERMS OF
REIMBURSING FOR SOME OF THEIR
COSTS AS WELL AND SO I WANT TO
BE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT --
THERE IS NOT -- IN THIS -- BILL
A SALE OF THE DEVELOPMENT --
CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AT
JACK'S EXACTLY ARE BUDGET MONEY
TO MAINTAIN THAT CENTER SO THAT
IS THAT CAN REMAINING AND GOOD
CONDITION -- I'VE SPENT THE LAST
ONE I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
[inaudible]
OF SENATOR BILL I'M SO SORRY.
CENTRE BELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU -- MADAM MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I I AM AS
STATIC ABOUT -- THE FUNDING FOR
THE PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED.
AND I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS -- LET'S LET'S LET'S
FACE REALITY HERE THIS IS THE
MAN THIS IS.
GOOD MAGNITUDE.
A HUGE INCREASE FOR THE PROGRAMS
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND WE NEED TO CONSIDER THE
FUNDING FOR THESE.
PROGRAMS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
DISABLED AND I THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSOME FOR MAKING THIS A
PRIORITY IN HIS BUDGET -- HE
TALKED ABOUT IT HE DISCUSSED IT
WITH THE COMMUNITY.
THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLED
COMMUNITY.
AND HE FULFILLED HIS PROMISES SO
THANK YOU GOVERNOR NEWSOME THANK
YOU FOR THE LEGISLATORS IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
OFFER THEIR FINE WORK ON THIS
AND EXPANDING THE THE FUNDING.
AND I REGION I VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM -- SACRAMENTO FOR
CLEAR FIND THE ISSUE AROUND
CINEMA DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND I
WILL WAIT AND HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
TO A DEBATE WHEN WE GET TO THE
TRAILER BILL THAT CONTAINS THE
ALLOCATION.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
FOR THE RECORD COLLEAGUES THAT
WILL BE SENATE BILL. EIGHTY ONE
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
HI DALY.
NO DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER BY GONZALEZ.
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY -- TITLE
[inaudible]
BY.
JACKSON HI BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
BY MERRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KATHY.
WIENER.
AYE WILK.
NOPE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WHAT CASKEY [inaudible]
BUT HEALTHCARE.
OUR EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY THREE BY THE
COMING INVASION FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACT GOING TO IMPLEMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE EMPLOYMENT
FOR YOUR BILL COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL EXTEND THE DURATION OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS FROM SIX
WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS.
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THE BILL ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT THE NEW EXCLUDED OR EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT RELATED TO
A BARGAINING UNIT.
AND WERE HIRED AFTER JULY ONE
TWENTY NINETEEN ARE SUBJECT TO
THE EIGHTY EIGHTY EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION RIGHT FOR RETIREE
HEALTH BENEFITS.
SB EIGHTY THREE ALSO REPEALS THE
PAYROLL DEFERRAL WHICH REQUIRES
THE ISSUANCE OF STATE EMPLOYEES
PAYCHECKS ON JULY FIRST RATHER
THAN JUNE THIRTIETH OF EACH YEAR
THIS ACTION HELPS PAY DOWN.
DEBT I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CARILLO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL.
I GOT JOHNNY [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TOTAL.
I JACKSON HI BY JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL BY
MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
THE PILOT.
AYE WIENER.
BY WILK.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG.
THE VICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OO.
EIGHT FILE ITEM WHY DON'T YOU H.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR AND MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TO RELTE TO THE
BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL COLLEAGUES --
SB EIGHTY FOUR AMENDS THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT TO EXTEND
THE DEADLINE FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE TO MAKE THE ONLINE FILING
AND DISCLOSURE SYSTEM AVAILABLE
FOR USE BY FEBRUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON FILE
ITEM ONE AWAY.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
BY OUR SHEILA BY ADKINS. FIVE
BATES.
BY BILL.
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
BY KELLY GHETTO.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
BY DOT.
HI THERE AWESOME.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI.
JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN BY STONE BY A BURKE.
OUR KELSEY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI ICE FORTY NO.
ZERO ASSEMBLY A MEMONS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE OH NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHTY
FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN
FISCAL REVIEW AND THAT KIND OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND MAKING IN
PREPARATION FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATE TO THE
BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM.
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE RESOURCES
TRAILER BILL AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS THIS BILL WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE FOR THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND FOR TEN YEARS.
FROM JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
JULY ONE TWENTY THIRTY IT
REQUIRES CAL FIRE TO COLLABORATE
WITH THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE WHENSELECTING FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS.
IT SPECIFIES THAT THE LA -- IS A
NON VOTING MMBER OF THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND IT
INCLUDES OTHER CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET THAT I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I PORCHES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL.
HI JANE [inaudible]
NO DALY [inaudible]
NO DOT.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON HI ITUNES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
TIME ACQUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
BY KATHY BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
OUR EYES TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE TEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMAND BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AN
EQUITY TRANSPORTATION MAKING
PROGRESS THERE FOR TO TAKE
AFFECT ME THE BILL RELATE TO THE
BUDGET.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS THE
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL IT
AGAIN IT CONTAINS STATUTORY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE BILL DOES THE
FOLLOWING IT MANDATES THREE
PAYMENT OF ALL OUTSTANDING
TRANSPORTATION LOANS TO THE
GENERAL FUND IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY IT STRENGTHENS
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS IT REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO CREATE A STATEWIDE.
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
FUND INVESTMENTS IN SHORTLINE
RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE AND A MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES THE
CLOTHES ON USE FUNDS AND
TRANSFER THEIR BALANCES THE
OTHER RELATED FUNDS I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING ON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
BY PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
HI DOURADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WITH SO.
HI -- TADA HI.
JACKSON HI I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
OUR CASKEY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BUSH'S [inaudible]
BRADFORD HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE. FOR JUST
[inaudible]
CHANGE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHANGE.
OUR EYES THIRTY TWO NO SIX
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM.
ONE ELEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINETY
TWO BY THE COMMUNE BUT IN FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACCOLADES TAXATION
AND MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED BUT
SENATOR MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES SB NINETY TWO WAS THE
TAX EXEMPTION AND CLEAN UP
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THE BILL
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES RELATED
TO REVENUE TO IMPLEMENT THE
NINETEEN TWENTY THE NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING
UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TO ESTABLISH TO THE SALES AND
USE TAX EXEMPTION FOR DIAPERS
AND MINSTREL PRODUCTS.
IT LIMITS THE DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION THE BILL
YOU TO COLLECT THE PAYMENT OF
PASSED TAXES FROM CERTAIN
RETAILERS AND ADDRESSES THREE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN WHICH WE PASS EARLY THIS
YEAR TO IMPLEMENT THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
WAIT THEIR DECISION AND REQUIRE
THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS TO
CREATE A PROCESS FOR PERSON
FOLLOWING AN APPEAL TO CHOOSE TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE FOR CASES.
THAT DO NOT EXCEED CERTAIN
THRESHOLDS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CRISTINA GARCIA AND I HAD THE
THE INEQUITY IN OUR TAX LAWSUIT
OUT TO US AND WE BOTH WANT TO
REPEAL THE TAX SOMETHING
FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS SO WE
INTRODUCED A BIPARTISAN BILL. TO
DO JUST THAT.
THE TAX ON FEMININE HYGIENE
PRODUCTS IS AN UNJUST TAX.
GOVERNMENT IS TAXING WOMEN FOR
SOMETHING COMPLETELY OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL FEMININE HYGIENE
IS NOT A CHOICE AND SHOULD NOT
BE TAXED.
I KNOW MEN SOMETIMES WILL BRING
UP LIKE SUGGESTIONS HEY.
IF YOU GUYS HAVE HAVE A
SUGGESTION I'M MORE THAN WILLING
TO TO LISTEN TO WHAT OTHER TAXES
WE CAN REPEAL.
AS A PRO CO AUTHOR LEGISLATION
EXEMPTING THE SALES TAX ON
DIAPERS I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND FINALLY PROVIDE
TAX RELIEF TO FAMILIES.
I APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
THE GOVERNOR TO INCLUDE THIS IN
THE BUDGET IS NOT PERMANENT SO
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
BUT THIS IS A HUGE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION MEMBERS I HEARD
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHIANG ANY
OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
SENATOR MITCHELL HAS CLOSED AND
WE WILL NOW.
ASK THE SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY HER SHE LED A I ATKINS.
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES BY BRADFORD
[inaudible]
BY CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI [inaudible]
GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO HI -- TITLE HI JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
I HAMBURG.
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MORE LUCK [inaudible]
I ICE FORTY NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE TWELVE FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY THREE BY THE
CAMINO BUDGET THIS REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY IN THE STATE BUDGET AND
MAKING PREPARATION FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR MITCHELL COLLEAGUES THIS
IS THE CURRENT YEAR SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL.
THIS BILL APPROPRIATE TO HUNDRED
AND TWELVE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
SHORTFALLS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET THE BUDGET ACTIVE. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
COVERS COUNTY COSTS RELATED TO A
HOMICIDE TRIAL AND THE ENTIRE
BALANCE OF FUNDS ON ANTICIPATED
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE COSTS I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES.
HI BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY.
BY DODD.
AYE THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
HI.
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY AMARILLO [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG BOB AKOWSKI I WINNER
[inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI.
BUYS FORTY NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINETY
FOUR BY THE COMING INVASION
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT GOING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND MAKE IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
AFFECTED ME LEAD TO RELATE TO
THE BUT SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL
NINETY FOUR MAKE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PORTIONS OF THE BUDGET
BILL.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY EFFECTIVE
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THIS
TRAILER BILL MOVES THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE DJJ.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS TO A NEW DEPARTMENT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY THE NEW
DEPARTMENT WILL BE CALLED THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
ESTABLISHES GOLDEN INTENTIONS TO
PUT THEIR DJJ YOUTH WITH SKILL
BUILDING AND JOB READINESS
OPPORTUNITIES DILLON
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM BTWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
IT DIRECTS THE SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TO
CONVENE BY OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN A COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL
TO PROVIDE INPUT RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO D. Y. C. R. S.
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
THAT PROMOTE A COMMITMENT TO
IMPROVING YOUTH OUTCOMES
REDUCING THE TENSION AND
REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
THE D. Y. C. R. CHAU REPORT AS
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
REGARDING THE COMMITTEE'S INPUT
A RECOMMENDATIONS.
THROUGH THE YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IT
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA RE
ENTRY AND ENRICHMENT.
GRANT THE CARE GRANT. TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WITH IN
CORRECTIONAL SELL WITH US SAID
AIMS.
ADDITIONALLY IT CREATES A
STAKEHOLDER STEERING COMMITTEE
THE GUY THE GRANT MAKING PROCESS
THE BUDGET ALLOCATES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
THIS GRANT AS PART OF THE PRISON
TO COMMUNITY.
PIPELINE PACKAGE.
THIS TRAILER BILL OUTLINES AN
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENT
BEGINNING FEBRUARY FIRST F
TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING WHICH MUST INCLUDE
SPECIFIED INFORMATION.
THE BUDGET PROVIDE THIRTY FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING TO POLLS TO RESTORE THE
DEPARTMENT TO PREVIOUS FUNDING
LEVELS. TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS PRIORITIZE EACH YEAR
FOR THE USE OF FORCE AND DE
ESCALATION TRAINING.
FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS TO
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN EVER THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES REGULATORY
CHANGES PURSUANT TO THE
AUTHORITY TO AWARD CREDITS
EARNED FOR GOOD BEHAVIOR.
AND APPROVED REHABILITATIVE OR
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
BUT OPPOSE LADIES ON THE SENATE
I DO OR TONIGHT VOTE I DON'T
LIKE THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
PROVISIONS.
NOR THAT CHANGE THAT OCCURRED IN
JUVENILE JUSTICE I THINK IT'S
ANOTHER OF MANY STEPS IN THE
BUT THE APPS THE ISSUE HERE IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
AND WE KEEP TAKING SMALL STEPS.
THE MAKING THAT APPS PROGRAM
AFFECTED.
GETTING THE GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE WHO ARE
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING GUNS IN
THEIR POSITION OF POSSESSION.
HEY IT'S BEEN A LONG.
BATTLE.
DIFFICULT SOMETIMES WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
BUT SOME PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
IN THIS REGULAR REPORTING IT
WILL AT LEAST BE HELPFUL AND WE
CAN HAVE AN ACCOUNTING.
OF THE REGULAR PROGRESS. FOR
THAT REASON.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING ON SENATOR MITCHELL YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT
GIVES ME GREAT PRIDE TO BE A
SITTING MEMBER IN THE SENATE AT
A TIME WELL WE ARE BEGINNING TO
LOOK AT YOUNG PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THE
JUVENILES THAT WE HAVE TRIED AS
ADULTS OF LOCKED AWAY IN
FACILITIES THAT -- ARE NOT
CONDUCIVE TO THEIR GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT -- AND NURTURE ALL
WILL BE A BY GONE ERA AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD -- TO THE WORK OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION -- AND THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
WITH FOR THE CREATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
COLLEAGUES I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
HI THERE ALSO.
BY GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
BY.
BY HILL AYE HUESO BY -- TITLE HI.
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
THE REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
VIA CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
HI MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO AYE.
VICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS THREE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE ONE
FOUR MISTER SECRETARY
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
READ THE BILL NINETY FIVE BY THE
COMMAND BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AND
THAT KIND OF COURTS AND MAKING
IN PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
FACSIMILE BILL RELATED BUT
SENATOR MITCHELL.
BUT I'M PRESIDENT OF THIS BILL
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE COURTS PORTION OF
THE BUDGET ACT MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL WILL DO
THE FOLLOWING IT ALLOCATES
TWENTY FIVE OF THE REMAINING
FORTY EIGHT TRIAL COURT
JUDGESHIPS.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY REDUCING THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF JUDGESHIPS YET
TO BE ALLOCATED.
TO TWENTY THREE THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATE THIRTY POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
I'M GOING FOR THIS PURPOSE.
IT INCREASES THE CAP ON TRIAL
COURT RESERVE FROM 1% 23%
INCREASE IN THE CAPTAIN ABEL'S
COURTS TO RETAIN FUNDING TO
COVER IMMEDIATE COSTS FOR
BUDGETED EXPENSES.
SUCH AS PAYROLL AND OTHER
OPERATING EXPENSES IN THE EVENT
OF AN UNANTICIPATED ONE TIME
DISRUPTION IN FUNDING.
IT ALSO GIVES COURTS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS LOCAL
NEEDS ALLOWS COURTS TO ADDRESS
THE MID YEAR COSTS CHANGES.
LASTLY THE BILL MAKES AN
APPROPRIATION OF FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS RELATED TO BUSINESS
INTELLIGENCE AND DATA ANALYTICS.
THIS INCLUDES THE VALUE WAITED
IN IMPLEMENTING A PILOT PROGRAM
FOR NEW TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING INTELLIGENT CHAT VIDEO
REMOTE HEARINGS.
AND NATURAL NATURAL LANGUAGE
VOICE TO TEXT TRANSLATION
SERVICES WITH THE PLAN OF
EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM ALL
JUDICIAL BRANCH ENTITIES.
THIS PROGRAM SUPPORTS DELIVERY
OF THREE OF THE FUTURES
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS AS
DIRECTED BY THE CHIEF JUSTICE I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER MITCHELL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR BORCHERS.
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT'S WHEN
WHEN MY ABSOLUTE SUPPORT -- TO
TO THIS ITEM -- WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY IN A DEFICIT WHEN IT
COMES -- TO JUDICIAL OFFICERS
AND I THINK THIS IS DEFINITELY A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
HOPEFULLY.
WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER IN EACH
SUBSEQUENT YEAR THAT GETS TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE BECAUSE WHEN
OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
GETS BACK LOG.
AS THE OUR OUR COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE SUFFERS SO ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR BORDER CITY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
I FELT PLEASE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BILL BY PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I TAUGHT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ.
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
HI JACKSON ARMY BY JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCKED.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG.
POWER CASKEY HI BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
VICE FORTY NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. ONE
MOMENT IF WE COULD
.
I'M READY MATTER PRESIDENT VERY
GOOD.
THE LAST ITEM UP THE FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTEEN FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE
LAST OF THE BUDGET TRAILER BILLS
FOR TODAY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND ACTING
TAXATION MAKING PURPOSE
THEREFORE CLEARING THEIR THROATS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS A BEAT NINETY ONE IS THE
LOOPHOLE CLOSURE IN SMALL
BUSINESS AND WORKING FAMILIES
TAX RELIEF ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS BILL MAKES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE TO WORKING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS CHANGES THAT EITHER
COUNTY BURDENS AND CUT TAXES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES IT ALSO CLOSES
CERTAINLY POLL THAT ALLOW
EXTREMELY HIGH INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
AND BIG BUSINESS TO REDUCE THEIR
TAX BURDEN.
THIS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
DO THE FOLLOWING.
IT'S SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDS THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FROM APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S A 110050% INCREASE
BY PROVIDING AN ANNUAL
REFUNDABLE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT.
OF ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
QUALIFY TAXPAYER WITH THE CHILD
OR CHILDREN SIX YEARS OF AGE OR
YOUNGER.
IT RAISES THE MAXIMUM INCOME TO
QUALIFY FOR THE STATE EITC TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
INCREASING THE TAX CUT FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INCOMES FROM
APPROXIMATELY 1-400-023-0000
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
MEMBERS THESE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN THE I. T. C. WILL
RESULT IN AN ADDITIONAL SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT WILL GO INTO THE POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING POOR.
THE EXPANDED PROGRAM IS
ESTIMATED TO REACH TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE BILL EITHER THE COUNTING
BURDENS AND PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION AND TAX CUTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGH NINETEEN
TWENTY WITH ONGOING TAX CUTS
AFTER THAT.
THIS IS ACHIEVED BY INCREASING
THE THRESHOLD FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO USE EASIER
ACCOUNTING METHODS FROM LESS
THAN FIVE MILLION OF GROSS
RECEIPTS TO LESS THAN TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OF GROSS RECEIPTS.
THIS ENABLE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
AVOID USING THE TWO SETS OF
ACCOUNTING BOOKS ONE FOR FEDERAL
TAXES AND ONE FOR STATE TAXES.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL
SMALL TAX REDUCTION THAT ENABLE
ROLL OVER A FIVE TWO NINE
EDUCATION SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
INTO WHAT'S CALLED ACHIEVING A
BETTER LIFE EXPERIENCE ACCOUNTS
ABLE ACCOUNTS.
AND EXEMPTS FROM INCOME STUDENT
LOAN DEBT FORGIVEN DUE TO DEATH
OR DISABILITY OF THE BORROWER.
LASTLY THE BILL CLOSES SEVERAL
LOOPHOLES IN BIG BUSINESS TAX
BREAKS SUCH AS NUMBER ONE
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF NON
CORPORATE BUSINESS LOSSES THAT
CAN OFFSET OTHER PERSONAL INCOME.
THIS ONLY APPLIES THE LOSSES
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A SINGLE FILE FILER
OR FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR JOINT FILERS.
SECONDLY ELIMINATES THE TAX
DEFERRAL OF LIGHT KIND EXCHANGES
EXCEPT FOR REAL PROP PROPERTY.
THREE ELIMINATES NET OPERATING
LOSS CARRY BACKS. FOR A CLOSER
THAN EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION
LOOPHOLE THAT ENABLES COMPANIES
TO DOUBT COMPENSATION FOR
EXECUTIVES ABOVE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS BY.
FRAMING IT AS A BONUS.
THE CLOSURE OF THESE LOOPHOLES
WILL NOT IMPACT THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND WILL ALIGN WITH WHAT MOST
OTHER STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HELP ALREADY DONE.
THESE ACTIONS WILL ALSO RESULT.
IN APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS.
THIS BOULDER RESPONSIBLE BILL
PROVIDES.
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME WORKERS IT EASES BURDENS
ON AND PROVIDES A TAX CUTS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS.
ALL WITHOUT RAISING TAXES ON THE
MIDDLE CLASS FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS SENATOR MORLOCK FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR DIRAJA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATE BILL NINETY ONE
COLLEAGUES IS.
SELECTIVE CONFORMITY WITH THE
TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT.
CHERRY PICKING THOSE THAT RAISE
TAXES AS SENATOR IT'S AB NINETY
ONE JUST IN CASE ANYONE IS
FOLLOWING THIS IT IS AB.
NINETY ONE I HAD LOOK AT MY
NOTES AND I THOUGHT OH I WROTE
DOWN THE WRONG THING AND NOW I
WILL CHANGE IT BACK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
GOING TO START OVER.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
YOUR FIVE MINUTES BUT THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
ALTHOUGH THE THEMES FOR AB.
NINETY ONE OUR SIMPLICITY
CLARITY AND POLICY.
IT WILL KEEP TAX PREPARERS FULLY
EMPLOYED AND SINCE I COME FROM
THAT PROFESSION I GUESS THAT
MIGHT NOT BE A BAD.
THING TO DO -- BUT THEY WILL BE
PREPARING TWO DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT TAX RETURNS ONE FOR
THE FORM TEN FORTY AND OTHER FOR
THE FORM.
FIVE FORTY CONFORMITY WHICH USED
TO BE IN THE OLD DAYS JUST
PULLING OUT THE AMOUNT YOU PAID
IN STATE INCOME TAXES OFF OF THE
FORM FIVE FORTY ARE PROBABLY
LONG GUN.
BUT THIS BILL IS A TAX INCREASE
THAT WILL GENERATE AN
ANTICIPATED ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THE PAY FOR AN INCREASE IN YOUR
INCOME TAX.
CREDIT REFUND OF ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
SO TAXES ACTUALLY THREE TIMES.
THE AMOUNT OF THE PURPORTED
PURPOSE FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
AND COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY THE HIGHEST TAX STATES
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO AS A MAJOR PIECE OF TAX
LEGISLATION THIS HAS NOT GONE
THROUGH GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE TO HAVE
HAD SOME PUBLIC DISCUSSION --
BUT IT IS NOW JUST GOING QUICKLY
THROUGH BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW.
AS A TRAILER BILL.
YES THREE DISTRIBUTING WEALTH.
IN A IN A PRETTY MASSIVE FORMAT
WHICH SHOULD REQUIRE A PUBLIC
DEBATE SO COLLEAGUES FOR THESE.
AND OTHER REASONS I AM OPPOSED
TO AB NINETY ONE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- SENATOR MORE LAW
[inaudible]
SENATOR RAZA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I I RISE
TO SUPPORT A. B.. NINETY ONE I
DO HOWEVER HAVE A BIG CONCERN.
HOUSEHOLDS THAT CONTRIBUTE
ALMOST THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES YET MANY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE PROSPERITY
THAT THEY ARE HELPING TO
GENERATE FOR CALIFORNIA.
JUST BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER THEY
USE TO FILE THEIR TAXES OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
LOSE OUT THE MOST BECAUSE EVEN
OF ONE PERSON IN THE HOUSEHOLD
FILE THEIR TAXES WITH AN AYE TEN
NUMBER THE ENTIRE FAMILY IS
DENIED THE CREDIT.
IF I TEN USERS MEET EVERY
REQUIREMENT WHY ARE THEY LEFT
OUT.
WE TAKE THEIR TAXES AND EXCLUDE
THEM FROM THIS CREDIT.
CHILDREN OF THESE WORKING
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE ALREADY
TWICE AS LIKELY TO LIVE IN
POVERTY COMPARED TO CHILDREN IN
WORKING NON IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
THE GOAL HERE WAS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
FAMILIES WORKING FAMILIES ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO EXCLUDE
THEM FOR THE CHILDREN AND THE
FAMILIES WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE
CAL E. I. T. C..
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM WILL
CONTINUE TO BE OUT OF REACH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR DORADO ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. ONE AB.
NINETY ONE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM PRESIDENT I'LL JUST SAY
THAT -- THE LANGUAGE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL IS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE FOR SEVERAL MONTHS NOW
ON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WEBSITE --
THERE WERE NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT IT -- IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY OUR LETTER.
HI ATKINS.
BY BATES [inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DALY [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR
TITLE.
BY.
JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR.
HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
HI MONNING.
BY MORE LARK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY KATHY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ALL EYES TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN
ON THE URGENCY OUR EYES TWENTY
SEVEN THOSE TEN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THE MEASURE EXCUSE ME THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES.
ARE WE ARE DONE.
WE ARE WITH THE ITEMS TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS.
ON THE FOLLOWING ITEMS.
FILE ITEM NINE TEN ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN AND ONE OH THREE MISTER
SECRETARY STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM.
NINE PLEASE LIFT THE CALL.
AND PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY STONE.
HI OUR EYES FORTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT THE POINT
IS CONFIRMED.
FILE ITEM TEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO OUR EYES THIRTY FIVE KNOWS
THREE THOSE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY STONE.
HI ICE FORTY KNOWS HEROES
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
STONE.
HI ICE FORTY KNOWS.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM OF ONE OH THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
THE ALLEY [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS FIVE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
OUR WILL TRY AGAIN EARLIER WE
ASKED IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL TRY ONE MORE TIME
IF THERE IS ANYONE.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE AN ITEM?
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL 698-127-81440 SIX
THREE TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO SIX
NINETY TWO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE SENATOR RESOLUTION
EIGHT A SINGLE EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWO TWO SEVENTY TWO A
534-229-71716 ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TO ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN
SIXTY TWO TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
1-265-143-2330 FIVE AN ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF FORTY
ZERO SEEING AND HEARING NON
HIGHS.
FORTY NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
COLLEAGUES WILL NOW MOVE BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME TO ADJOURN.
IN MEMORY.
IF ANYONE WISHES TO DO SO
[inaudible]
SENATOR UP.
THE ROSTER WILL START WITH YOU
FOR BY SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MEMBERS
IT WAS WITH SADNESS WE ADJOURN.
I JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF NOT THE
ABLE LARRY LOPEZ.
PASSED AWAY ON MAY NINETEENTH
AFTER LOSING HIS BATTLE WITH
CANCER.
HE WAS BORN IN BOYLE HEIGHTS IN
LA.
MANY GROUP IN NORWALK IN A
FAMILY THAT HAS LIVED IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR SIX
GENERATIONS.
HERE'S INSPIRED BY BURKE PUT ON
AND SAYS OUR JOB IS TO BECOME AN
PRIOR TO ATTENDING COLLEGE AT
UCLA AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
DOMINGO'S HILLS HE ORGANIZED TO
THE WALK OUTS FROM HIGH SCHOOLS.
IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE FOR
EDUCATION REFORM SHE WAS
INVOLVED IN SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS
TO WIN LARGE SCALE IMMIGRATION
REFORM IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND BECAME
INVOLVED IN THE CAMPAIGN TO
ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
OBTAIN DRIVER'S LICENSE.
HE SERVED ON THE SCHOOL BOARD OF
SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA FOR SIX
YEARS.
HE SUED THE CHALLENGE THE USE OF
ENGLISH ONLY RECALL PETITIONS AS
A VIOLATION OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT AND ONE IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT
FEDERAL APPEALS COURT.
AFTER WORKING WITH THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE HE
FOUND THE NOT A SANTA ANA
CHAPTER OF A MONDAY -- HE GOT A
NASTY NOT.
A GROUP THAT FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
THE HISTORY OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS IN LOS ANGELES WILL
DEFINITELY INCLUDE HIS NAME.
AND DESCRIBE HIM AS AN END
INFLUENTIAL IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
ACTIVIST AT A TIME WHEN
LEADERSHIP AND PASSION ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
HE WAS A FIERCE DEFENDER OF ALL
ANGELENOS CALIFORNIANS AND
AMERICANS.
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
ESPECIALLY BY HIS BELOVED WIFE
MARIA ROSA IN THERE FOR YOU
CHILDREN.
WE HAVE SUFFERED A TREMENDOUS
LOSS OF THE NEXT DREAMILY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR IMMIGRANTS IN
THE STATE AND THEN THIS NATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING NOT
THE WILL LOPEZ AND SENDING OUR
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO AND IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE MISTER LOPEZ. FOR
HIS FAMILY PLEASE SEND OUR
CONDOLENCES.
AND BEST WISHES TO THEM AT THE
TIME OF LOS.
SENATOR STERN FORESHORES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF CHAD
SOMEPLACE.
A YOUNG MAN FROM THOUSAND OAKS
WHO ACTUALLY DIED.
LAST MONTH IN A MOTORCYCLE
ACCIDENT A FLASHING YELLOW LIGHT --
ON HIS MOTORCYCLE JUST THREE
WEEKS BEFORE HIS HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION.
A CHAD FOUND JOY IN THE OUTDOORS
FISHING SURFING RIDING HIS
MOUNTAIN BIKE LIKE A LOT OF
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN DO.
IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS AND THE
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT FROM THE
COMMUNITY IS BEEN OVERWHELMING --
THEIR GRADUATION FOR HE WAS AT A
CONTINUATION SCHOOL THE CANAL
VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL LAST WEEK.
I CHAIR WAS LEFT OPEN FOR HIM.
HIS FAMILY WAS PRESENTED WITH
HIS DIPLOMA.
A FIRST SO FOR THIS LIFE CUT
SHORT.
AND FOR THOSE HE LEFT BEHIND
LIKE HIS MOTHER BRIT.
THIS FATHER BRAD THIS SISTER
CAITLIN.
AND HIS BROTHER JUSTIN IS
GRANDMOTHER THELMA AND ENTAIL
KEY AN UNCLE MARK AND COUSINS
AND HIS GIRLFRIEND HAILEY.
AS BEST FRIENDS GEAR AND RYAN
THIS WHOLE COMMUNITY THOUSAND
OAKS WE'RE ALL HURTING BUT OR
MORNING IS LOSS OF LIFE CUT
SHORT TOO SOON.
WE ASK THAT WE IN TURN IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER STERN -- PLEASE EXTEND
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY --
TOOLS LOVED ONES AND TO THE
COMMUNITY WHICH IS NO LONGER.
ABLE TO ENJOY AND THEY HIM
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
THERE ARE NO OTHER OF CHURN IN
MEMORIES.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANTED TO RISE TO ALSO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE RULES COMMITTEE WILL
MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND IF
THERE ARE NO OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS --
WE WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTIETH AT NINE AM THANK
YOU MA'AM THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED
WE RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM